hey guys I'm Ryan right now this would
be crazy we're gonna watch a movie clip
from a movie Disney movie based on a
Marvel comic it's called big hero 6 and
we're gonna watch a clip do it and yadda
yadda yadda we both really want to watch
it already I know it looks all good cuz
we reacted to the first trailer when it
came out so long ago well how long ago
was that oh man I I don't care
sorry there's just so many yeah man I
can't keep track
looks like cute Fiona pokken hello I am
baymax your personal healthcare
companion
hey hey baymax I didn't know you were
still active I heard a sound of distress
what seems to be the trouble
oh I just stubbed my toe a little I'm
fine on a scale of 1-10 ha ha how would
you rate your pain zero I'm okay really
Thanks you can treat now does it hurt
when i touch you it's okay oh you have
fallen on a scale of one to ten on a
scale of one to ten how would you rate
your pain zero it is alright to cry no
no no no it's a natural response I'm not
crying
I will scan you for injuries don't scan
me stand complete unbelievable you have
sustained no injuries however your
hormone and neurotransmitter levels
indicate that you are experiencing mood
swings common in adolescence diagnosis
puberty whoa what
that's an interesting insight is just
like except of the movie it would be the
trailer oh okay that's I said we're
gonna watch a clip of the movie before
we before we watch that somehow my brain
overlooked that if ELISA listens if you
would speak louder it's okay I forgive
you yeah whatever anyway big hero six
it's a cute introduction into the
characters I think that I mean matter it
didn't it had a kind of an offbeat tone
about it not like it's bad or something
but at the same time I was like the
trailers are so like energetic that I
wasn't expecting something to really
just take its time like that which i
think is cool because if it is more than
just some fast-paced movie and it has
scenes that really take its time that is
a better movie the heartfelt family
movie yeah I like the fact that they
slowed it down and they're not making it
about all the action about the
connection between the two
yeah what was cool about the robot was
yeah I mean he has the they did portray
it properly were he's supposed to be
kind of not the smartest robot not the
most intuitive robot but at the same
time he is still pretty cool and what he
can do I think that whole like scanning
the body and determining the brain waves
and all that stuff was really neat yeah
I do that with people actually all the
time really yeah I get it right now okay
do it
you're uh you're feeling uncomfortable
you're you're thinking that even though
I am in a loving relationship that you
still might be in love with me and
you're thinking how oh my god how does
Ryan know all this crap I'm caught but I
want to tell you it's okay Alyssa we can
still be friends just hmm okay I need to
give you my space I mean we need to
space it out just a little bit okay I'm
surprised you got all that I wasn't
expecting you to be so spot-on didn't
intend for this dynamic it's okay Alyssa
I mean you might even say sometimes you
be a little crazy but
people have been doing to call me that
but right now you just need to be a good
friend I'll be there I'll be supportive
okay
just don't touch me I'm gonna have a
girlfriend cut it up anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects oh yeah
and if you want to subscribe to Alyssa's
channel you can subscribe to all this
would be crazy
enjoy enjoy the channels Nick no Caro no
cerro santa Nichkhun acero dear Ryan I
live in Minnesota and I watch your
videos every single time I'm on a plane
because I work as a pilot cool wait it
hold the pilot wait if I wait if you're
a pilot you should be piloting the
planes now watching guys oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
I fell keep watching the videos yeah you
be paying attention keep watching the
videos that is awesome dude it's pretty
cool funny thing is that I'm actually
flying a russia for 19 hours you and
gaiter Martin or one of the best people
alive so can I get a shout-out it will
really mean a lot thanks man
I don't imagine gaiter Martin I mean
even I are cool and all but you know
it's like you know we're buddies it's a
competition
it's not a competition man dude I think
it is so cool you're going to Russia for
just 19 hours like honestly I'm actually
thinking about getting into a stewardess
thing work did you know that they tell
you that yeah yeah yeah so so fly more
often so you can catch ELISA it's cool
but NIC dude that is awesome man that is
a respectable job remember like remember
back then pilots I don't remember but I
know that they're still pretty snazzy
what do you but that damn pilots were
like you walk down with a pilot you're
like holy [ __ ] and I need up like ladies
on his left and right they still do that
no they don't yes they do have ladies on
their left and right yeah pretty much
anyway pretty much I'm talking about
like catch me if you can style either
way you're still badass okay face but
dude no that is awesome if you ever fly
down to California let me know I'm
coming because that's a respectable
[ __ ] job
next Hill Perez give me a shout-out no
can't say that almost said it he
basically said the n-word what's funny
is there's a lot of n words and
for some reason when we say the n-word
we know which n-word we're talking about
it's true it's only the woman out of so
if you look in the dictionary
you're a lot of n words yes yeah but
there's only one we truly define as the
n-word nextel perez you have caused me
to have an epiphany just now so you
deserve this shout out okay si he's
Perez work for it it's Perez so I'm like
dude I was banging this this.g car the
other day man and I didn't pull it out
and now we have like three children the
other day and I have three kids below me
I'm like well dude Texican girls are
known to reproduce at an incredible rate
oh I see gamer Bigfoot you did mr. Schad
I'm just telling you that right now
Paris met shout-out to Marie she is cool
as butts she is she is we just bump into
her uh yeah she is cool as butts butts
are awesome darris meds you know what I
love about hers I actually told her this
to her face just now every time I think
she dies and is not around just pops up
industry appears I love it she just
never fully disappeared she's there
she's here she's there so you mean if
she like resurrects from the dead you
kind of just look like yeah and yes
you're not like blown away by this
miracle why do you think I was like like
outside because I hadn't seen her in
freaking forever like a long long time I
know but that's how you react I mean if
you really thought she was dead you want
to react that way you know yeah maybe
right probably you would be like re
alive what about what about the plane
crash to the Bahamas where you save
people from the water but a shark ate
you
that is how a reason and I probably
gonna marry her anyway Darris man I let
you in on the future